Roberta thank you very much dear
Philippe honorable members ladies and
gentlemen
indeed if we look back
a little over 50 years ago the club of
Rome and the group of MIT researchers
published the limits of growth report
it mapped the interaction between
population growth
the economy
and the environment
and it came 50 years ago to a drastic
conclusion
stop economic and population growth
or else our planet will not cope
and as you know this report has sparked
a long controversy
for instance about the role of new
technology in the countering the climate
change
but instead of prolonging these debates
I want today to concentrate on one point
and that is a point that the report got
right Beyond any doubt
and that is the clear message
that a growth model
centered on fossil fuels is simply
obsolete
[Applause]
[Music]
this assessment has been confirmed time
and again
the recent ipcc report is just the
latest reminder that we need to
decarbonize our economies as quickly as
possible
and this is exactly why we put forward
our European green deal
building a 21st century
clean energy
circular economy
is one of the most significant economic
challenges
for our times
the European green deal is not only our
plan to fight climate change and become
the first climate neutral continent
it is also our new European growth model
for a prosperous
responsible
and resilient economy
it is our blueprint for a systematic
modernization of Europe's industry
because in the long run
only a sustainable economy can be a
strong economy
only a sustainable economy has a
resources to invest in healthier
and in a fairer tomorrow
only a sustainable economy empowers us
to reach the social targets we set
ourselves
at the Gothenburg and Porto's social
Summit
only a sustainable economy generates the
means to accelerate research
and development
for clean Technologies
so 50 years ago
the club of Rome could not completely
envisage for example
the potential of green hydrogen
it could not envisage
that we might drive this kind of
electric cars of today
or it might be able not to see the
future as we would have for example with
batteries where we recycled 95 of
lithium nickel and Cobalt it's not the
daily procedure today but we're able to
do it
but already 50 years ago
the limit to growth report acknowledged
that while fossil fuel-based growth was
unbearable for the planet
Humanity could devise and I quote
a different growth model model that is
sustainable far into the future end of
quote this is the mission that drives us
today and this is the spirit of the
European green deal
we do not have to start from scratch
our compass
in this endeavor
are the long-standing values the True
Values if you get it right
of the European social market economy
our social market economy was never
exclusively about economic growth
it always was about human development
it never had the sole goal of market
efficiency and liberalization to the
contrary
the social market economy functions in
the interest of the worker
and the community
it opens opportunities also to set very
clear limits
it rewards performance but also
guarantees protection for the big risks
in life
Beyond growth
it focuses on public goods
such as health care
education and skills workers rights
personal security Civic engagement and
governance good governance
our social economy market economy if you
get it right
encourages everyone to excel
but it also takes care of our fragility
as human beings
the values of the social market economy
have driven us since the beginning of
this commission's mandate
within the European green deal we have
always strived
to reconcile jobs
with the protection of the most fragile
people of our society
technological innovation
with climate neutrality
and we have stayed True to this approach
even as new crisis disrupted our
everyday lives
first when the pandemic hit us
our recovery plan Next Generation EU
has focused not only on restarting our
economic activities after the lockdowns
but also on Transforming Our economic
model
with a push to decarbonizing Industries
energy and transport
with an emphasis on digital skills and
digital infrastructure
with new Investments for schools and
hospitals Beyond growth
Next Generation EU takes care of the
Next Generation future
and then
last year
when Russian tanks rolled into Ukraine
and the Kremlin rolled out its energy
blackmail against us
Ed was it half here
it did Shake us to the Core
but not only did we guarantee Europe's
energy security
there were no blackouts
and protected vulnerable households and
companies
with a solidarity contribution from Big
energy providers
we also accelerated massively the
transition to clean energy and for the
very first time in history in 2022 we
generated more electricity from Sun and
wind than we ever did from gas and oil
while the CO2 emissions globally
Rose by one percent
in the European Union during this year
2022 we managed to cut emissions
by minus 2.5 percent despite the war
so this is the living proof it is doable
you can cut emissions and have a
prosperous life it is doable
foreign
a French writer and Nobel Prize winner
once said
one does not discover new lands without
having the courage
to lose sight of the old Shores
end of quote
and I have to look back once in the
1970s just one year
after the limits of growth report was
published
the Big Oil Crisis began
back then
our predecessors
chose to stick to the old Shores
not to lose sight of them
they did not change their growth
Paradigm but relied on oil
and the following Generations have paid
the price
we also experience massive crisis
we're choosing a different path
we are choosing to discover new lands
it's not trivial
today we are leaving the fossil fuel
growth model behind us
but the new lands are still blurred but
they are visible we can reach them we
know that our children's future depends
not only on GDP indicators but on the
foundations of the world we build for
them
it was Robert Kennedy back in the 1960s
who famously said
and I quote
that GDP measures everything
except that which makes life worthwhile
the health of our children
and the joy of their plague
and I'm sure
had he given his speech today
Kennedy would have included the sound of
Birdsong
and the joy of breathing clean air
today on a very fundamental level
we understand Kennedy's wisdom
the economic growth is not an end in
itself
that growth must not destroy its own
foundations that grows must serve people
and future Generations
this is exactly what you will discuss
today and the next two days
so thank you for inviting me and I wish
you a very good conference thanks a lot
[Applause]